[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et bienvenue à
tout le monde merci merci d'être là et
merci à tsx gd m'avoir invité et avant
de me présenter je voulais vous demander
quatre choses est la première et c'est
pardon excusez moi pendant mon récit
peut-être que et tu venais j je vais
partir à l'abattoir
le langage là bas et voilà c'est comme
ça
alors pardon excusez moi d'abord
deuxièmement et c'est que les questions
des personnels et c'est là personnel
c'est moi et j'ai vu je voudrais
demander c'est sûrement parce que quand
on ne croit jamais et des gardes et pas
une minute
mais une demi minute 3 secondes
simplement 30 secondes de silence pour
les animaux victimes
un moment qui vous parle dans le monde
il ya des millions d'animaux qui sont
une trace de se faire massacrer
alors s'il vous plaît c'est ce que je
veux partager avec moi des vhu 30
secondes
s'il vous plaît
c'est merci beaucoup cette faillite
merci à vous bassirou tous trois sur mon
dieu vous demandé de retenir une phrase
s'il vous plaît c'est pas trop long les
assez courte
cette phrase c'est et baisse la tête
fermer ta gueule et fais ton boule et si
t'es pas content dégage ça peut vous
servir pour le nord-est lors de récits
dieu vous l'a répété au cours d'un style
de pardon le staff est athlète fermer ta
gueule et fait ton boulot n'était pas
content dégage ne peut vouloir
réinventer répéter vous êtes prêt s'il
comptait jusqu'à 3 s'il vous plaît allez
à 2,3 reste à terre
fais ton boulot ferme c'est pas content
voilà les chasses aux bon voilà je
m'appelle know if you're ici à pddaa je
suis né le 4 avril 1969 à düsseldorf en
allemagne
quand j'avais trois 3 mois mes parents
d'origine espagnole mon père élire le
cas avec un mouvement et ils sont partis
ils sont rentrés chez eux et des
vacances mais pendant ces vacances par
hasard mon père il a trouvé un ami à lui
en veut à leurs envies et un ami de
lycée qui l'a proposé le travail n'a pas
besoin de travail d'attention ferme la
ferme à les vaches initial la plus
grande des gars disent car ces nectars
de faire des intérêts de kilomètres
parcouru 400 hectares et puis une des
plus grands d'espagne
et alors j'ai grandi dans le milieu
rural à la campagne au milieu des deux
animaux les vaches et les cochons de cet
émoi il s'est crispé sait élever des
animaux pour le faire tout et on les
mangeait bon j'ai grandi de cellulaires
des prix tout petits jusqu'à mes 20 ans
gérez et développez malheureusement mes
études à l'envié me suis barré d'avoir
l'armé ça fera passer après à votre
gauche jusqu'à que iosca cannes 2001 et
par amour par amour à sophie la maman
des mes deux enfants qui sont ici
présents s'il vous plaît 5 ans et vous
voilà
merci beaucoup
en dominant mais voilà je suis venu par
amour amour à limoges halim au sacrement
et la voilà après sept ans de vie
commune et 2008
malheureusement elle et moi ça sa part
voilà on est tellement déjà et qu'il
venait de naître et mais c'est pas si
t'es pas là là là là vont solution non
plus alors du coup on a décidé de se
séparer
et l'an 2008 je me souviens des trous et
solo donc tout semble pas répondre là
j'avais de suivre quand je suis venu de
commencer à travailler des serveurs mais
j'ai décidé d'arrêter en observation en
longueur et une formation et après
information ni travail ni femme ni
boulot ni difficile ni famille est ici
j'ai trouvé tout seul à la rue et à
dormir dans la voiture on revient sur
les copains et une dépression avait des
problèmes l'accord aussi le problème
d'alcool mort on m'a suivi pendant pas
mal pendant des maris pendant pas mal
d'années de ma vie aujourd'hui c'est un
combat encore tous les jours je me bats
et mais bon c'est pas de sac est devenue
information
voilà en 2008 j'ai besoin dans la rue à
la rue je n'avais pas de travail je
serais même pas que vous payez la
pression et l'angleterre deux enfants
est alors la dépression je suis partie
en espagne près de ma famille de ma mère
et de ma soeur et après 4 mois je n'ai
je suis fait une double fine santé et
c'était mieux mais un niveau encore une
fois c'était ici en france et dire qu il
pas le voir alors j'ai décidé de faire
limoges et de trouver de boulot mais
malheureusement pas de travail fixe
procéder qu'à des missions intérim
les petits mission à droite à gauche et
jusque 1 2010 en 2010 la même année jean
karim il n'est pas le seul abattoir est
ce que vous voulez territoire mais sinon
mieux
écoutez la finalement si vous travaillez
du bien à la fin vous savez en cdi a
quand même depuis trois ans de galère
qu'il ne savait pas qu'on paye et la
pression de la part de mes enfants
des fois ils étaient obligés d appeler
ma mère avant elle boit un thé arjona
sophie propose enfin pas pour moi pour
cette fois on n'y arrive pas bon voilà
alors je me suis battu chaque année et
chaque jour mon combat c'est vrai mon
combat c'est monsieur faure d'accord et
et une 2010 là il commence à travailler
à l'abattoir au moma en main on m'a
prévenu on m'a prévenu
mais c'est comme s'il ya eu ce qui vous
savez voir et bovo amos vous avez peur
de voir les animaux morts ben non madame
d'organisation fleuve et l'océan
écoutez moi ça me plaît pas non plus
intéressant mais ça m'a fait pas peur de
mon père qui était chasseur pêcheur
moi j'ai vu des animaux retour depuis
tout petit l'agglo glas non ne peuvent
pas trop et vous avez le vertige de
voltige faut travailler quand ça sera
oratoire et mais oui les bêtes ils sont
à six mètres de hauteur
il faut que les descendants des nacelles
et si votre foi pour cette peine du
voilà comme ça vous êtes appuyé que au
projet nous d'accord vous êtes branchés
les carcasses quelques traits fils
d'accord moi je vais travailler aller
6,6 en cdi en plus je n'étais pas à fond
et voilà c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé à travailler à l'abattoir
municipal de limoges l'abattoir public
le plus grand de france
il ya trois chaînes vo van hove en
cochon % on tue des centaines
elle laissait mitaine un décennie ten
d'animaux par jour ces profils kabatwa
et à niveau survie que ces publics alors
n'importe qui peut aller vous avez un
cochon a tué aragno vous passez vous
arriver là mais les enceintes et titre
vraiment que voilà le demain en trois
jours plus tard pour le coffre est le
mec avec son drap un atout propre plan
alors la catastrophe à la grèce merci
bon bref
et on continue quel jeu mois après par
intérim au départ quand tu donnes et les
petites poste qu'on allait poste paraît
compliqué avec des bouts de la chaîne ça
qu'il faut une formation sur le champ et
pendant deux semaines et après d'autres
postes que l'aquarelle mineurs d'user on
t'explique voilà quoi qu'il faut faire
vraiment 6,7 vers le bon et après ça
c'est cette mère à tous la journée
n'était pas dire à d'autres arrivent
suffisant pour la journée voilà de la
gare jusqu'au discours dont bon bref et
comme ça pendant les six mois les six
mois des petits postes à droite à gauche
et c'est en plus compliqué que les
autres mais moi il est désolé toujours à
fond et après six mois lors un chef
ils viennent ici mais ces gars si on est
content on est content
avec votre travail ça vous dirait des
fermes et un contrat de six mois et
appelée ans et des enfants mais bon
comme les toilettes de cdi
bien sûr que oui bien sûr que oui
et du coup et ça c'est une vieille photo
de la faire repartir la ferme aux
débiteurs vous dis voilà avec piscine et
où les années 70 vous parle la série 4 5
ans est assez bonne franquette encore
vivants d'avoir une piscine chez
françois tension bon voilà sophie c'est
pour un pied survenue à limoges en
france voilà maintenant que parler de
l'abattoir la race limousine blason
prestige salon de l'agriculture
tous les sens l'ocde france où il ya des
animaux la main la limousine et de l'art
une accorte connu d'entre eux france
tout l'europe voire tout le monde
moi j'essaie de chefs français qui se
rend à tokyo il jours que les polonais
la race limousine
après 3 après même pas 12 ans après tout
ça d envoyer à l'abattoir
il réussit à passer les étapes quand
j'ai signé
surtout quand j'ai signé le cd mon
statut
il a changé un peu l'intérimaire voilà
travail temporaire a cédé voilà on
dirait pas mais à voir c'est vous
on n'y a pas grand chose de novateur
c'est beaucoup d'accord en partie
seulement voilà tout un statut du
vendredi le répète il change alors c'est
parti le redda qu'il ait commencé à
connaître tous les postes de battoir à
ce moment tous sénat a à z
le camion qui les charge du vent
jusqu'au camion qui cherche la carcasse
pour partir en france entre l'europe et
la clé c'est à qui j'ai découvert donc
les découverts et non cet abattoir
tous les jours on tue à part les
centaines d'animaux culture d'accord le
cochon agneaux les bobos à part des
tutsis centaine d'animaux calcul par
jour on m'a tuer une moyenne d'une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de vaches à
lait des vaches qu'elles sont distantes
malheureusement jamais les dj filmer
pour le bon je peux pas montré aussi
masse les animaux sont un peu choquant
alors je vais essayer d intello mettre
d'accord bulls et la minute de plus
comme l'expliqué bien de retour les
images merci et bon moi je comprends
qu'il faut trouver des animaux pour les
manger
ben moi dieu voilà a prédit beaucoup de
respect pour les gars mais pour le
végétarienne je suis presque rien dedans
et je mange pas beaucoup de bien mais ça
m'arrive encore de manger un peu pas de
la vienne la rouge présente donc une
vingtaine à une trentaine d'animaux des
vaches pleines de vastes plaines et donc
développer le foetus est tout petit mais
parfois le fait aussi le point de naître
le volet grand mais pas au point de
naître à tel point qu'à moi ça
m'arrivait déploré des décennies des
eaux d'été le pomper pour le beatle me
lève toi quoi comment pgt ça la poubelle
quoi comment on peut faire ça quoi voilà
la première fois que j'ai vu un gros
gros gros gros comme ça des petites
idées de génie c'est comment on peut
faire ça quoi comment on peut faire ça
pourquoi on fait ça une vache plein une
mère qui va te moment c'est tout vie en
même temps c'est pas une c2 pourquoi
inséminer artificiellement pourra tout à
fait j'ai passé tellement de questions
je vais trouver la réponse mes vaches
pleines les bains le vol de fonte des
neiges et le point de naître
ça arrive et que la machine mais va dans
le camion stabulation pendant la nuit
quelques clics et là qu'il attend
tellement mais la peur parce que les
animaux en selle à la mort le sang et la
base il est passé une heure mais il va
pousser et pousser toute la nuit tout la
vie parce qu'il s'agit de danger elle
veut pas redescendre le camion 20 pas et
3 mai toi mec allait mettre des coups de
bâton lie à coude et correctrice 200 200
il est temps qu'il aille vite et être
tranquille en attendant jean charest
pourquoi alors la montée des forges déjà
elle voulait pas monter mais pas dans le
camion
le jeune t'es déjà alors il avance il
n'est pas là et le petit matin il arrive
l'oublier chef qui fait quoi avec à
salah qui ont fait comme plus qu'on fait
avec comme d'habitude et ce n est simple
bien sûr que vous apprenez à l'abattoir
700 animaux qui rentrent ils ne sont pas
qu'est ce qu'on fait mâcon des matraques
landes a hobo d'accord égorgé l'eau
avant de rien quoi
comme quoi ici comme ça et si l'on reste
à tête fermer ta gueule fait le boulot
si t'es pas content les gages cette fois
l'idée que devant l'ordinateur qui
tablait sur 10 cents du chef celui de
vétérinaire le service vétérinaire
asselah assez là où ce vétérinaire la
whey une vache qui l'open des maîtres va
il est vrai il est où le service
vétérinaire
qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est en détruisant
ils sont à jour et protéger les animaux
revanchard et 12 mai devant une vache
qu'il est plein comme il ya plus loi qui
l'interdît qu'est ce qu'il fait le mieux
petit budget là celui-là est devant
c'est le gauchiste équipe est allée
passe ou ça c'est un bon sens un bon
tiens ils respectent même pas la peine
loupé d'argumentation qu'il y en a dans
les abattoirs qui la respectent eux la
respecte même pas le même et enfin on en
vient à oublier qu'il ya une faute oui
mon petit foot on fait des fautes foot
une petite photo avec les petits bouts
des merles mais je vais me
orienté oubliez ça on va oublier ça et
le vétérinaire de tous ces interdits de
travaux et 7 propre consommation humaine
et qui a de la merde encore dans la
carcasse
moi j'ai oublié peut-être et pourquoi
lui a tapé lui il a mis le temps pour
lui et pour terminer une dernière
question et cela ne répond pas gardez
les pour vous la réponse et vous
paraissent avoir imaginé
soyons fous imaginez-vous et pour un
secondaire et que vous travaillez
d'interrogatoire enfin chaque rendez
vous d'accord mais pas comment vouliez
vraiment très con mauvais pas oublier
comme moi si on poussait le cadre un
chef chef de service vétérinaire
directeur sur directeur responsable
sanitaire responsable des productions la
corse vous vous êtes voilà un autre
chinois encore moi et vous savez vous
êtes au courant
vous le savez que tous les jours où une
vingtaine des vaches qui vomit passé
avec le veau au point de naître vous
faites quoi vous mettez vous à leur
place pendant une minute
vous ferez quoi vous pas que baisser la
tête mais la gueule et fait ton boulot
être en amour est parce que je pense que
vous êtes sûrs de voir au champagne
c est l après-midi d'accord selon mena
vous ferez cobra fermer la bouche
derrien et ramassé val d'argent
et pour finir est cette fois ci
détermine encore salée un conseil mettez
vos meubles
est ce que je me dis vous demande pardon
parce que ce matin des vêtements de vos
données et de conseil
la prochaine fois que vous entrez dans
son restaurant blason prestige cotation
boosheri blason prestige surtout des
grandes surfaces blason prestige vous
recommander agricole
s'il vous plaît réfléchissez à quel
vaches il appartient cette entre corte
merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]